The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
WOLFGANG KETTERLE:
So, good afternoon.
Let me start by
presenting something
I learned today during lunch.
I had lunch with
three colleagues
and we discussed entanglement.
And, well, I'm telling you the
story a little bit differently,
but the question
which came up is
you have two
harmonic oscillators.
One harmonic oscillator
is in the ground state,
one is in the excited state.
And then you have the
harmonic oscillators
where the excitation
is here and there.
Is that an entangled
state or not?
It's a real question.
I want to think about it.
AUDIENCE: What's the physical
nature of these oscillators?
AUDIENCE: Can you
distinguish these?
WOLFGANG KETTERLE: OK.
Who's working with ion types?
There's a few people I know,
a few ion types here at MIT.
If this is ion-- what is
a good ion? [INAUDIBLE]?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
WOLFGANG KETTERLE:
Strontium plus, OK.
So if it's strontium plus, which
can be in the quantum state v
equals 1 or v equals 0, and you
have another strontium plus ion
in a second ion
[INAUDIBLE]-- and it can be
in the [INAUDIBLE]
first excited state--
isn't it wonderfully entangled?
Two systems far away.
You can manipulate them, you
have two particles, and then
two quantum states.
It fulfills with flying
colors all the qualities
you want to see of
an entangled state.
But now I can say, if I call
this harmonic oscillator,
I have two optical fibers.
And you know, a single-mode
fiber defines a harmonic
oscillator, namely the
electromagnetic field
in the single mode.
And if I put one
excitation into this fiber,
I have a photon here and
here I have zero photon.
Or here, I have one photon
and I have zero photons.
So if you look at
the fiber, you would
say the fiber has two states.
It can have an
excitation or not.
And if you use now that
approach, you would say,
well, I have an entangled
state between two fibers.
However, I can realize
exactly that state
by having a beam splitter,
by having one photon coming
on the beam splitter,
and then the photon
is coupled into
one of the fibers.
So in other words,
there is an ambiguity
which I want to point out
between whether you have
a state of one particle--
one photon into two fibers--
or whether you have
two fibers which
can be in two different states.
So there is often an ambiguity,
what do you call the state
and what do you
call the particle?
So at our lunch
conversation it came up
in a somewhat different context,
but people would actually
say that splitting
a photon-- sending
one photon across
a beam splitter
fulfills, if you
interpret it in that way,
fulfills the definition
of entanglement.
I know our wiki page and
Professor Schwan would probably
not agree, but welcome to
the frontier of research
where different people
have different opinions
and certain definitions
are still being worked out.
But there is one
thing which is real.
We have here two different
harmonic oscillators,
ions oscillating in a harmonic
oscillator potential or photons
in a single mode.
I remember from 15
years ago, there
were papers that show if you
put the ion in a cavity or such,
you can really
transfer the quantum
state from the single
photon from this harmonic
oscillator-- the
harmonic oscillator
of the electromagnetic
field-- to the harmonic
oscillator of the ion.
So if we want to hold
onto the definition,
which I'm not sure if you should
that this is a single photon,
a single particle
cannot be entangled,
well I know and people reminded
me at lunch the there is
a protocol to [INAUDIBLE] map
the single photon in the two
modes after the beam splitter
onto an entangled state
of ions.
So if you focus here on
the photon and say a single
particle cannot be entangled,
you're facing the problem that
there is a protocol which would
transfer something which you
call not entangled to
something which is entangled.
I hope you enjoy that.
It's not clear what
is the particle
and what is the excitation.
There's really ambiguity.
Any questions?
OK, so that's what part
of my lunch was about.
I thought since I wanted to
remind you of the schedule.
In a few hours I will
actually be heading to Europe
and say there for next week, so
therefore no classes next week.
We've already made up for one
class with the Friday class,
and the week later we
also have three classes
and we've made up for the week.
I've just put down here
for you the PSET schedule.
I kept the Monday due date so
there is one PSET every week.
We have wonderful
material for those PSETs.
The due date is now for this
week not the day of the class,
but you will find a way to
get your homework delivered
or email it to the TA.
Any questions about schedule?
I think that has been
clearly announced.
There was a question
in the last class
about if you have
a density matrix,
if any arbitrary density
matrix can be regarded
as a partial trace
of a pure state.
I was not immediately
clear-- I thought it was,
but I wasn't sure.
But the proof is so simple
that it fits on three lines.
You can simply take
a density matrix,
you can double up
the Hilbert space,
and define our pure state
in a Hilbert space of twice
the dimension, and
you immediately
see that this density
matrix is the partial trace
of a pure state.
So therefore, if you
want, you can always
say the density matrix is sort
of entangled-- you are entitled
to the opinion that the density
matrix always originated
into a pure state, but the
entanglement [INAUDIBLE]
to the other subsystem
have been broken.
And I showed you last
class that if you
are one of the Bell states,
the most entangled states
in a fully-entangled state
between two particles,
but you just look
at one particle,
one particle isn't just a random
states with a density matrix
which is a unity matrix.
Now let's get back to
where we left it on Monday.
I introduced to
you-- and I just want
to remind you of that, because
[INAUDIBLE] I introduced
to you this famous phenomenon
of Hong-Ou-Mandel interference
which is the
following situation.
If you have 50/50 beam split and
you have two identical photons,
you will never get
single photons out.
The photons are bosons.
They want to be together.
And so you will always
get two photons,
but you don't throw on which
side of the beam splitter.
Now, this is important
because we can now
use the Hong-Ou-Mandel
interferences
effect to entangle atoms.
So the element we will take
from this beam splitter
is the following.
We will have atoms emit photons.
But then we create
entanglement probablistically.
When these photons have passed
through beam splitters--
and I tell you
everything about it--
and both detectors make a click,
if both detectors make a click
you know for sure
that the two photons
at the input of the beam
splitter were not identical.
Because if they were
identical, only one detector
receives light.
So we will actually used
this home interference
to project out photon states
where the two photons are not
identical because they have
difference polarization.
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Does [INAUDIBLE]
include the phase.
Like if you were in phase
lab with those photons,
would it be still?
WOLFGANG KETTERLE:
Frequency very important.
Polarization important,
timing is important.
A single photon has no phase.
It's a global phase.
And if you have
many single photons,
your many photon state
is a product state
of those single photon states.
And all of the
individual phases--
if you want to hold onto
this concept for a second--
just become one big
multiplicity phase.
Yes, Nancy?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
WOLFGANG KETTERLE: Oh,
everything [INAUDIBLE].
easy experiment.
But I think the beam splitter
is probably not-- I mean,
beam splitter is a piece of
wonderfully polished optics.
And in Germany and
elsewhere, people
have really learned how
to do exquisite optics.
I don't think you're
limited by optics right now.
What I would think
is difficult, if you
have two photons
on a beam splitter,
they have to be in
the same spatial mode.
So if you have to fibers and the
fibers are not fully aligned,
or you have another mode
which is [INAUDIBLE],
or if you have a lens which is
distorting your Gaussian mode,
you mix other modes
in so all this
creates non-distinguishability.
But I think equality
of optics is probably
the least of your concerns.
So actually for today, because
I'm out of town next week,
I want you to have
something to think about it,
I already pre-wrote
some of the slides.
So I can go a little bit faster.
Give me feedback.
If you think I'm going too
fast, I will not do it again.
But I felt I can probably
have a reasonable speed
by making annotations to
what I've already prepared.
So the situation
is the following,
we want to entangle two atoms.
We have two atoms which
are both in the excited
state in the scatter light.
And they can go to two
different ground states.
Think about two different
type of ion states.
I call them U and
D, Up and Down.
And when because
of selection rules,
one state can be reached
with one polarization.
The other state can be reached
with the other polarization.
And I call this polarization H
and V, horizontal and vertical.
In reality, this will be
circular polarization,
so you may want to transform
from linear to circular
after the fact.
But for just the
discussion right now,
I assume that horizontal
polarization leads
to one state,
vertical polarization
leads to the other state.
So therefore, if you have
two atoms-- and Chris Monroe
in Michigan did the
experiment where he really
had two different
vacuum chambers with two
different ions, they
both emitted photons,
and then the photons came
together on a beam splitter.
So that's what you should
sort of have in mind, two ions
here and there.
They both emit a photon.
And after the have
both emitted a photon,
each ion is in a
superposition before you
make any measurements.
It can be in up with
a horizontal photon
or it can be in down
with a vertical photon.
So that is the state of the ion.
And so we have two of those.
And then you want
to detect photons.
And the goal now is by
using beam splitters and all
those tricks, that the
detection of photons
and the outcome of a measurement
will project this product
state of two atoms
with their photon
into a bell state for the atoms.
So measurement on
photons can take
two atoms which were
completely remote,
had nothing to do
with each other,
and suddenly they're
in a Bell state.
And this is done by the
probabalistic measurement.
And so let's-- so
lets develop it.
Our initial state is UH plus DV.
This is system one.
And we have the direct product
with our second ion trap
apparatus which
has done the same.
The ion has emitted a photon and
we don't know anything about it
at this point.
And now it is important, if you
want to have entanglement you
cannot go and measure
the polarization,
because this would project an
individual ion into a state
and would not have entangled it.
So what we are doing is we
are allowing the two photons,
one photon here,
another photon here,
they come together
at a beam splitter.
Actually, before I do it let me
just perform the product here.
So what we get is-- well,
it's just multiplying it out.
UU for the atoms,
HH for the photons.
UDHV plus DUVH, plus DDVV.
So what you want
to do is we want
to send this beam--
the photons of course,
the atoms stay put--
onto a beam splitter.
Now, I can do it more rigorously
by keeping all the terms
until the end of
the calculation.
But I hope it's rather obvious
that we want to have it--
if we want to send
it on a beam splitter
and then we want to detect
that both detectors make click.
That requires the photons
to be distinguishable.
So therefore, those
two terms will not
contribute because the photons
have the same polarization.
So we are now using a
protective measurement.
We want to find out what is
the wave function of the atoms.
Measurement of one photon
in the modes A and B,
which are the output modes
of our beam splitter.
So it needs one more line.
The output of the
beam splitter is--
so I'm only focusing now on the
two terms which can give rise
to two clicks at the
two different detectors.
So I will factor out UD.
And now we have the two photons
hitting the beam splitter
and each photon goes into
a 50/50 superposition.
So I take know this
horizontal photon.
And since we don't mess
around with the polarization,
it's still a horizontal
photon, but the photon
can be now in mode B or in
mode A in one of the output
modes of the beam splitter.
And I label that
as 0,1 plus 1,0.
Now for the second photon, it
had a vertical polarization,
so it's a vertical photon.
The second photon is coming
onto the beam splitter
in the other input port,
because we have taken the two
photons from two
different experiments,
from two different
experimental setups,
and now we combine
them so that we'll also
be now in a superposition
of 0,1 and 1,0.
But you know that one mode
transforms with a plus sign
and the other mode transforms at
the beam splitter with a minus
sign.
So that's how you should
look at those terms.
And of course, from of
this here, from this term
we get something very
analogous, 0,1 plus 1,0.
And for the other
spatial mode, the minus
sign from the beam
splitter, 1,0.
OK, now we are done.
Now we are detecting photons.
So we want to look at this
wave function and ask,
what happens if in port
A-- the output port--
we find one horizontal photon,
and in B it must be vertical
because the photons have
to be distinguishable.
So where do we have
one photon in mode A?
In horizontal it is here.
And here it is this
product with the minus sign
where we have-- no,
sorry, the plus sign.
Here we have one
photon in the vertical,
so this is with a plus sign.
But we have a
second possibility,
one photon in mode A horizontal
happens here with a minus sign.
And one photon in mode
B vertical happens here.
So in other words, form
the term which gives rise
to this measurement process,
we have a plus UD here,
and because of the
minus sign, a minus DU.
So therefore, if
you would detect
the photon with the polarization
at this point, which
we don't do, this polarization
gives rise to UD minus DU.
We have a second possibility to
have a click at each detector,
and this is when we reverse
the two polarizations.
But in this case, you can
just add the wave function.
You get the atomic state,
the sign doesn't matter.
So you have to measurements, two
possibilities in polarization,
but they both have
the same outcome.
They generate this state, so
the result of all that is I've
shown you that the two
atoms are left now in--
and now I put back in the
correct normalization--
in one of the Bell states.
So whenever you detect the two
single photons in coincidence
on both counters,
at that moment you
know what you have is
an entangled state,
a Bell state of atoms.
Now, the big issue
here is efficiency.
Your photon detectors
are not highly efficient.
And I was sort of only
looking at combinations
where we have this
double detection.
Most components of
the wave function
will give the
Hong-Ou-Mandel effect.
The two photons go in one way.
So therefore, you have
to prepare your system,
have photons emitted,
and in most of the cases
you will not get
the state you want,
so you have to keep on trying.
And usually those
experiments are
heavily limited by the very,
very dismal success probability
of creating the state you want.
And when you want to extend
it, not just to two atoms
entangled, to three atoms
and four atoms entangled,
then you get a smaller
number to the power n
for your efficiency.
So this probabalistic
preparation doesn't scale up,
but it is a very simple scheme,
it's a very powerful scheme,
and it has been used to create
teleportation of atomic states
and do some tests of Bells
inequality and the EPR Paradox.
And here is the
abstract of a paper.
So-- well, this was just
2008, so just a few years ago.
And what you see here is
that here are one meter apart
two [INAUDIBLE] ions.
They emit light.
The light goes through
an optical fiber.
And now, after
the beam splitter,
when you detect one
photon you don't
know which ion has
emitted the photon.
So this is exactly the
setup which I described.
Of course, in an
optical fiber you
have the two good polarizations
are horizontal and vertical
in the polarization
maintaining fiber.
So therefore, the
light which originally
was emitted in a circular base
is-- angular momentum selection
rules-- transformed into
linearly polarized light
using the [INAUDIBLE].
Any questions?
Yes, Nikki?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] create
the initial state [INAUDIBLE]
atom [INAUDIBLE] one
state [INAUDIBLE]
make sure that the ions
state is a pure state, not
a mixed state, [INAUDIBLE]?
WOLFGANG KETTERLE:
Good question.
So first of all, if
you think about it
you will discover more and
more experimental challenges.
What people must have used there
is sort of a storm laser pulse
that you have more than
overkill to make sure
that with a very,
very short time window
both ions are excited.
The ions are in a pure state,
and then they emit a photon.
And if you have
one system prepared
which can emit a photon, but it
has a branching ratio of 50/50,
if it's an isolated
system, it will
have a superposition state of
photon in one polarization--
let's say a sigma plus photon
going to a magnetic quantum
number state m equals
plus 1 and a sigma
minus photon going
to m equals minus 1.
And this is a pure state.
The mixture only comes
if you're not careful.
If you have a
magnetic field and you
don't shield your
magnetic field well,
or you have some
magnetized materials
and you were not
aware of it, then that
means that you get
different phase shifts which
you can't calculate for, so
now you have a random phase.
You don't know it, and
if you have ignorance
you have to trace out or you
have to average over the phase.
And then your pure state
becomes a density matrix.
But the quantum
mechanical process itself
of a particle having
different branching ratios
is a pure system.
It undergoes unitary
time evolution,
and it stays in a pure state.
And the state which is
populated by two ions, both
emitting a photon
simultaneously,
is exactly the state I've
written down for you.
But you're absolutely right
that decoherence is an issue.
You have to be very careful
with magnetic fields.
You probably want to work with
atoms which are non-magnetic.
So you want to where the spin
is only a nuclear spin which
is much less sensitive with
a magnetic field, and so on.
Other questions?
AUDIENCE: So as soon as
both detectors click, then
[INAUDIBLE] so that
you can no longer
make use of that entanglement?
WOLFGANG KETTERLE: No, no wait.
Look here.
We have a state which has atoms
in a state and two photons.
So this state has
four particles.
We detect two particles
which are the photons.
And the atoms are untouched.
The atoms are then afterwards
in an entangled state.
So we have a bigger
system, we do a measurement
of part of the
system, and we have
arranged things in
the skillful way
that the moment we know the
outcome of the measurement
is such and such, we
know in which quantum
state the rest of the system is.
And this protocol
means that the atoms
are left after the
outcome of the measurement
is such and such, the atoms
are left in a pure Bell state.
OK I've used the word
Bell, Bell states
so often, I think it's time
to talk about what Mr. Bell is
famous for, namely
the Bell's Inequality.
So I said already
in the introduction
for the quantumness of
light and entanglement
that it is the EPR Paradox
in the Bell's inequalities
which a lot of people,
including myself, think
is the deeper essence
of quantum physics.
It really shows that
quantum physics is not just
classical physics
with wave character,
it goes way beyond it.
So I want to demonstrate
that with Bell's inequality.
And the formulation
which is very simple,
and I want to present it
here, is an inequality,
which is-- I mean the name.
Many Bell's inequalities now,
you have different states,
different detectors, and you
can derive Bell's inequalities
which are then violated
by quantum physics.
And what I want to present
here is the CHSH inequality.
That's Clauser,
Horn, Shimony, and--
AUDIENCE: Holt.
WOLFGANG KETTERLE:
Yes, thank you.
So the situation
is the following.
We have something
which decays, something
which emits two photons.
Maybe an atom in
an excited state,
and it does a click clack,
a two photon cascade.
One photon goes to
Bob, one goes to Alice.
Or I always try to
stress similarities
between light and atoms.
We discussed the
experiment where
you take a mercury
molecule, you dissociate it,
and then Bob and Alice
each get an atom.
And you can say these
photons has a polarization
or the atom has a spin.
But Bob and Alice can now use
different Stern Gerlach figures
in x and y, at obscure
angles, circular bases,
I mean you name it.
But what happens is because
it's a spin up, spin
down, horizontal,
vertical polarization,
it's a two-level system
which is immediate.
And after a Stern
Gerlach filter,
you have only two combinations.
We call it plus and minus.
So in its most general
form, what we assume
is that Bob does measurements
in a basis, if you think.
Think about a spatial
orientation of a Stern Gerlach
filter called S, where the
outcome is plus minus 1,
t where the outcome
is plus minus 1,
and Alice has her own choices.
And we want to
assume now that this
is everything is
classical probability.
That if you just write
down this expression--
don't ask me where
it comes from.
This is probably something
which people wrote up
after they found
something interesting
and try to prove
it or simplify it.
You just write down
QS, RS, RT minus QT.
You can then rewrite it
by factoring out S and T.
And now the next step
is because Q and R
are-- they're are in each
measurement 1 or minus 1,
either this is 0 or that is 0.
No sorry, one is 0, one is 2.
And therefore, this kind
of funny combination
of letters for every measurement
is either plus or minus 2.
Now we do many measurements,
and the probability
for a certain outcome
that the variable Q--
there's a certain probability
that the outcome is Q,
so you sort of use this pretty
much probabilistic thing
that the system has a
certain probability to B.
And this is of course
the assumption,
the probability is that
the particular comes
with a certain probability
in the state q, r, s, t.
Of course you should
scream, q, r, s, t commute,
but this is classical now.
They don't commute with each
other quantum mechanically,
but [INAUDIBLE] in a moment.
So then you simply put--
by multiplying each event
with its portability, you
put now brackets around it.
These are expectation
values, and what
you have is an inequality
that this expression, which
is the correlation between
certain measurements
between the quantity
QS, RS, and so on
is smaller or equal than 2.
I mean it's very, very basic.
And that's why I wrote it down.
I don't want to spend
a lot of time on it.
It's just classical
probabilistic reasoning.
So now what are we doing
quantum mechanically?
We want to prove that quantum
mechanics cannot be reduced
to this classical reasoning.
So we want to show that
this inequality is violated.
We have a source or
entangled photons.
We've talked about how
we can entangle photons.
And now we measure the
quantities Q, R, S, and T.
And just to give you an
example about the many possible
choices, Q can be a
linear polarizer and R
can be a circular polarizer.
S can be a linear
polarizer at 45 degree,
and T can be a
[INAUDIBLE] plate followed
by a linear polarizer
at 45 degrees.
Well, that sounds like
many trig functions,
but we're not going into it.
You have to choose
your polarization.
There's a certain scheme that
linear polarization is not
orthogonal to
circular polarization,
so there's a certain
theme behind it.
And if you would work
it out by just looking
at entangled photons,
the entangled photons
are in a state,
let's say HV plus VH.
They are correlated
in polarization
or spin up, spin down with the
down spin [INAUDIBLE] state.
And you can just
work out what is
the polarization
when you detect it.
And what happens is that a
simple but tedious calculation
says that all those quantities
QS, RS, and and RT are equal.
Here we have a minus sign and
they are all 1 over square root
2.
And that means that instead
of the classical inequality,
that this quantity
is smaller than 2.
We find that this is
2 times square root 2.
And the fact that
this is larger than 2
has been experimentally
confirmed
with larger and
larger precision.
Actually, the person who
gave this [? CUA ?] seminar
a week ago,
[INAUDIBLE], was part
of the team with [INAUDIBLE]
who did one of the very, very
first measurements violations
of Bell's inequality
in the '80s some 30 years ago.
So I mean, this happened
rather recently.
So the math is trivial,
the result seems trivial.
It just shows that the world
is quantum mechanically and not
classical.
And a lot of papers
have been written
and discussions have been had
about what does it really mean?
What does it mean
about the world?
What does it tell
us about the world?
So so the implication from
the established violation
of Bell's inequality
and the CHSH inequality
is that when we assumed that the
state has definite values of Q,
R, S, T before observation,
we have to give up that.
Or we have to give up that a
measurement performed by Alice
does not influence Bob's
experiment, Bob's measurement.
So in other words, what I
formulated here is the locality
principle that what happens in
one location cannot influence
what happens in
the other location.
Well you can say maybe
there's some secret channel
sending [INAUDIBLE]
the speed of light.
But people [INAUDIBLE]
to create links
to put the detector so far
away that even a [INAUDIBLE]
at the speed of
light could not have
influenced the
other measurement.
So there has been
after the first
Bell's inequality
experiment, there
have been a series
of experiments
to avoid all of those
loopholes that there
is some unknown secret
communication between the two
detectors.
The first one is the
principal of-- sometimes
I think a more
philosophical word
than physical word, "reality".
That those quantities
are real and they
should exist before
we measure them.
So the outcome of
Bell's inequality
is-- the violation of Bell's
inequality is, at least one
of them, at least one
of these principles--
reality-- at least one
of these principles
does not hold in nature.
So either reality or
locality are violated.
Any questions?
And maybe just to connect
it to what I've said before,
one reason you saw that here
in the title, Bell's inequality
with two remote
atomic [INAUDIBLE].
Those experiments got
a lot of attention
because Bell's
inequality is something
all physicists talk about.
And when you do it
with photons, there
is always the
detection loophole.
You don't have perfect
photon to detectors.
And some people said,
well, maybe the violation
of Bell's inequality comes only
from the photons we detect.
The undetected
photons would make up
for the violation of
Bell's inequality,
and Bell's inequality
is not violated.
I mean, that almost sounds like
that nature wants to fool us.
The photons team up
and say the photons
which are detected
behave very differently
from the photons which
are not detected.
But these are at least
logical loopholes.
And graduate students spend
half of their Ph.D., or maybe
several graduate students
spend their whole Ph.D.
In building such an
experiment which is now--
you get a famous
paper out of it.
And your research has
attention, so you know.
I didn't sleep so much, so
maybe I'm not too serious now.
But this is great research.
I mean, this is really
pushing the limit
of our understanding
of quantum physics.
And Chris Monroe is a
wonderful physicist.
And we are in the
same [INAUDIBLE].
So if you have a
Bell state of atoms,
and I told you how you get it
also with a lousy efficiency
but you get a Bell state.
If you now do a measurement
of those Bell state
and you measure violation
of Bell's inequality, atoms,
they don't run away.
You can detect the atoms
with 100% probability.
You can shine a laser light
on them, hundreds, thousands,
millions of photons until they
have scattered enough light
that you know
100%, I've detected
the atom in it's quantum state.
So Bell states with atoms, one
real world application of them
is to test violations
of Bell's inequality
with atoms which do not fall
into the detection loophole.
Our next unit is
partially motivated
to show you what all this
entanglement can do for us.
So I mentioned that
entanglement is a resource.
It's something useful
like energy is a resource.
And so maybe ultimately there
should be a stock market,
and you can buy so and so
many bits of entanglement.
And you have to pay
for it because there's
something you can do.
And let me introduce
what can be done with it.
If you have one photon
at frequency omega,
and you have an
observation time-- you
do a measurement
over time T, then
the precision at which
you measure the frequency
is fundamentally limited by, you
can say time energy uncertainty
by the Fourier theorem, that the
uncertainty and the frequency
of a single measurement
is 1 over the time T
you had to detect or to measure
the frequency of the photon.
But now we have n photons.
And that means that the
uncertainty in the measurement,
which is now small
delta omega, is
delta omega for a single photon.
But you know, when you do n
measurements, and average n
measurements, you gain
by the square root of n.
And this is regarded as
the fundamental shot noise
limit of measurements.
But now assume we can
do something fancy.
We can make a super photon.
We take our n photons
of frequency omega
and make one photon
of frequency n omega.
Now we have only one photon.
The frequency uncertainty of
the measurement is delta omega,
but this is now the uncertainty
off the n times more
energetic photon.
So therefore, if you're
interested in the quantity
omega, which is the frequency
of the single photon,
we have now made an improvement
over the standard shot noise
limit by square root n.
So everybody follows?
So that's just a
[INAUDIBLE] experiment.
If you can take n
photons-- I've told you
how we've talked about the
[INAUDIBLE] oscillator, how
we can pump a crystal.
And in your homework
assignment you
do a nice calculation
with a Hamiltonian.
One big photon in, it
breaks into two photons.
The reverse process is
frequency dot doubling.
So if you would not measure n
photons individually, but first
ate up their frequency by
making a photon of n times
the frequency and then
look a single photon,
you have now, you measure
all the photons together.
And therefore, your
accuracy improves
by a factor of n and not just
by a factor of square root n.
So that tells us something.
If we do something with the
photons, if we entangle them,
there is a possibility
to vastly improve
the standard limit
of measurements.
And so people who are
really interested in it
are people who push the
limits of precision, people
who build atomic
clocks and want to get
the last little bit of
accuracy which is possible.
So they have already exhausted
all technical possibilities,
and the next thing is now, well
maybe entanglement and sort
of subtleties of quantum
physics can come to their help.
So this shows you
what is possible.
But now I want to tell
you how it can be done.
So what I first want to do
is, before we can improve
over the fundamental
shot noise limit,
I have to show you how
the fundamental shot noise
limit naturally emerges.
So I want to introduce to you
beam splitter interferometers.
Interferometers are there
to measure phase shifts.
You split a beam,
you combine it,
and if there's a phase
shift you notice if.
You get interference fringes.
And I want to show you that very
naturally to standard quantum
limit, the shot noise emerges.
But then we are ready to
look at our description
of the interferometer and
say, where can we now change
the rules to put in more
quantum-ness or entanglement
and eventually get
higher precision.
Since the standard quantum
limit is well know,
I want to rather
quickly go over that.
So the goal is that we want
to measure a phase shift.
And my first simple
deviation of the phase shift
is that in this picture of
the quasi probabilities,
the coherent state is
a circle like that.
The width of the
circle in natural units
is 1, but the radius of that
is alpha of the coherent state,
which is square root n.
So now if you ask how well
with this uncertainty can
I observe the phase of the
photon which circulates
in this quasi
probability plane, you
find that the phase is
1 over square root n.
Or based on your homework
assignment number one,
you can say we have some
Heisenberg uncertainty
between photon
number and the phase.
And in a coherent state,
the standard deviation
in the photon number
is square root n,
and you again get the
standard quantum limit.
Let's now obtain the
standard quantum limit
from a real measurement
device, because this
is what we want to
generalize for entangles,
[INAUDIBLE] state, and
all the special things.
So an interferometer
is the following.
It consists of two
beam splitters.
After the second beam splitter
we have two detectors.
And the quality we
will measure will
be the difference of
the two photo currents.
And if you don't
do any phase shift,
we know the two beams
splitters are just
the identity transformation.
But now we put in a phase
shift, and the question
is, what is the smallest
phase shift we can measure?
What is the accuracy
measuring this phase?
We have discussed at
length all the elements.
So we have a beam
splitter, a phase shifter,
and a second beam splitter.
You know that the phase
shifter is a rotation in z,
the beam splitter is a
rotation in-- was it X or Y?
Looks like I think Y
because of the i's.
Just a warning here,
in this section
I use a beam splitter which uses
a different phase convention.
But they are all equally
apart from some phases.
So by multiplying
the three matrices,
we get the transformatrix for
the [INAUDIBLE] interferometer.
So the output CD
is this matrix here
which is a simple rotation
times the input state.
And our measurement
is the difference
in photon numbers in
the two output modes.
So it's D dega D minus C dega C.
So what we can do now is we can
obtain C and D from the input
modes A and B. So
therefore we can now
express our signal in
terms of the input modes.
When we know what we put
into the interferometer,
because we know all its elements
we know what we can get out.
And this is done here.
And the phase which appeared in
the rotation matrix, the phase
shift in the
interferometer appears now
as a cosine phi and
sine phi contribution.
And we have sort off-
the cosine and sine phi
have two operators
as a pre-factor.
In one case, it's A dega A minus
B dega B. In the other case
it's a cross-term, A
dega B plus B dega A,
Now we will be more specific
what is signal and noise.
I just want to tell you in
the standard way of operating
the interferometer you have
only one beam in the mode A.
You take a beam, you split
it, you recombine it.
B is nothing or the vacuum.
It may introduce some noise.
But if you have a lot of
intensity in the beam A,
it is this term which
dominates, and you find fringes
as a function of the
phase shift cosine phi.
Whereas what comes here is
sort of more the vacuum mode.
It gives rise to noise terms.
So if you ask, what is
the expectation value
for x, this x operator,
it varies co-sinusoidally.
And there is a special
point for a phase shift
of 90 degrees when we have the
steepest slope and the highest
sensitivity.
So these are sort of all
just setting the stage.
Which we are interested in
is, if we now have an input
state of light--
and as you know,
there's all of this noise.
There's the fundamental noise of
the vacuum, or coherent state,
of Heisenberg's Uncertainty.
And this means when we
do repeated measurements
we will have a
variance in the phase.
And we want to know, what
is the fundamental limit
on the standard deviation in
the measurement of the phase.
Well, the standard
deviation in the phase
is nothing else than
the standard deviation
of what we measure in
divided by how sensitive it
is to the phase.
So by taking this
expression for M,
M is an operator X plus cosine
phi plus something times
sine phi.
We can now evaluate
this expression.
This will actually appear
several times today,
and it's also a key question to
one of your homework problems.
So this is sort of what
defines the accuracy
of the interferometer.
And what we have here
are expectation values
of operators.
And now we can--
and that's what we
will do for the rest
of this lecture.
We will look at this expression
for different inputs states.
Coherent state, single photons,
[INAUDIBLE] light, entangled
state.
So that's what
you're going to do.
So if you take the
derivative of dn d phi,
the cosine becomes a sine.
A minus sign, the
sine becomes a cosine.
And if you specialize
to the situation, which
is where the slope
is very steep,
a 90 degree phase shift
around this point, our phase
sensitivity is given by
the expectation value
of the variance of the operator
y divided by the operator x.
So now we are ready
to plug things in.
The first thing is of
course the coherent state.
For the coherent state, our
input to the beam splitter,
one is a coherent
state, the other one
is a vacuum in mode A and B.
We had expressions-- let me
just scroll back-- for x and y,
expressed by the operators
a, b, a dega b dega.
So therefore we can
calculate that now.
And x is nothing
else than the number
of photons in the
coherent state.
And this is our signal.
And y is 0.
This was the noise term.
And the variance
in y-- we're just
doing commutators--
is given by n.
So therefore, if we
calculate the square root
of y square over x for
the coherent state input,
we take the square root of y
squared, which is square root
n, we divide by n, we obtain
the standard shot noise limit.
Sure, what else
should we expect?
So now we know how
to use the formalism.
We can now apply
it too-- we can go
from the most classical state
of light, the coherent state,
to what I regard at least for
a single mode the most quantum
state, namely a single photon.
Remember when we talked
about the G2 function,
G2 function can only
be smaller than 1
for non-classical states.
And for the single
photon it's 0.
That's the biggest violation
of the classical equation
that G2 has to be
larger or equal than 1.
So now we're really dealing
with a quantum system.
And the question is, what will
we get for the single photon?
So for the single
photon we want to use
the dual-rail representation.
We want to use the powerful
formalism we have used.
After the beam
splitter, the photon
can be in one mode
or the other mode.
We call this in the
dual-rail representation
the logical 0 or the logical 1.
So in this
representation, when we
start with a photon in one input
mode, this is the logical 0,
the beam splitter is
directing the photons
into one mode or the other
mode, but this is a single qubit
rotation.
The phase shifter is another
single qubit operation.
The second beam splitter
is another operation.
So by just using
the rotation, we'll
find out what is
the output state.
So we start with the logical
0 with the photon in one mode.
The beam splitter creates
a superposition state.
Remember, we have
the interferometer,
and in the lower arm
we put in a phase.
So therefore, the lower arm gets
multiplied with a phase shift.
And then it goes again through
a beam splitter, which is just
another rotation, and with that
we obtain the output state.
And so the output state
is now a superposition
of the logical 0
and the logical 1,
and we've picked
up a phase shift.
So no we ask-- we have the
beam splitter, phase shift,
recombiner, and
now we are asking,
what is the probability to
detect the photon in one
of the two output modes.
We just put a counter there.
And this probability is nothing
else than the probability
to have a logical 1,
because a logical 1
in the dual-rail
representation means
the photon is in one mode.
The logical 0 would
be the other mode.
I felt if I would spend three or
four times as much time on it,
it wouldn't increase
your understanding.
You may have to sit down
and look through it,
but it's just really
putting matrices together,
[? single ?]
photons, mapping it.
Every step is
trivial and is what
we have done in a
different context before.
So the result is
that the probability
of finding the [? single ?]
photon in our detector
has a cosine phi factor.
So that's how we measure phase.
Our counter, the probability
that photons arrive.
If phi is 0, the
probability is one.
If phi is 180 degrees, all the
photons go to the other mode.
I mean, that's what you'd
expect an interferometer to do.
But now comes the
interesting question.
How precise can be
measured the phase?
Remember, in the coherent
state, the coherent state
had fluctuations in the photon
number of square root n,
and this gave rise to the
standard quantum limit.
A single photon is
a single photon.
There is no noise.
We always measure
a single photon
if you would simply detect the
number of photons in the input
state.
But we are not doing that.
We have sent the photon through
an interferometer in order
to measure the phase.
And now we have-- and
this is a result of this,
I would say, trivial
calculation that this is now
the probability to
observe a photon.
Well, there is not a whole lot
we can learn from one photon,
so we run the
experiment n times.
And what we get is a
binomial distribution,
just a coin toss
with probability P.
What is the variance in P?
It's not a Poissonian
distribution.
It is a binomial distribution.
Of course, if the probability is
1 you detect all your photons.
There is no uncertainty.
If the probability is 0 you
detect 0 with 0 uncertainty.
So therefore, the
expression for the variance
of the binomial distribution
is p times 1 minus p.
If not, I admit I had
to refresh my memory
about the binomial
distribution yesterday evening.
So therefore, when we repeat
the experiment many times
and we have sent into
our interferometer
m photons and we
measure n clicks.
And n over m is our measurement
for the probability.
This measurement of the
probability has noise.
And the noise is a variance
of the standard deviation
of the binomial distribution.
This expression for P
put into the variance
of the binomial distribution,
and a little bit
of triganomic
manipulation gives us
the result on the
right-hand side.
And we want to know what is
the uncertainty in the phase.
I mean, this is what
we want to measure.
Well, the uncertainty
in the phase
is the uncertainty in our
measurement, which is delta P.
And then we have to divide by
how sensitive the probability
is with respect to the phase.
So we take this expression
of the probability
as a function of the
phase, take a derivative,
and then by doing the ratio
of this over that we find 1
over square root n.
So it doesn't make
any difference
if you put the n photons
into a coherent beam
and run our
interferometer or if you
go through the great
pain of preparing
each photon in a
non-classical flux state
and just operating
the interferometer
with single photons.
In both cases do we obtain
the standard quantum limit
1 over square root n.
Now we are really
ready to see how can we
improve on the shot noise?
It seems that unless we
do something special,
we will always
get square root n.
I've already shown you
at the beginning that's
the shot noise limit
is not fundamental.
Just take this
thought experiment
that you take the n photons
through a highly nonlinear
process, you create one
photon of frequency n omega,
and then you have more
precision of this measurement.
So there must be a way to have
a precision which scales 1
over n and not 1
over square root n.
The mathematical augment
related to our treatment
of the interferometer
is the following,
our signal was A dega
A minus B dega B. Well,
if one of the input
mode dominates,
A dega A is the [? photon ?]
[? number. ?] So this sort
of looks like the
[? photon ?] [? number ?].
But if we now find a
scheme-- and I will show you
that this is possible-- that
this cos term A dega B plus B
dega A, which is some form of
quantum noise, as we will see,
is 0, well what do we get now?
So let's hope that maybe
by some squeezing--
I will show you several versions
which show you how quantumness
can give us more
than short noise.
And one example will be
that by squeezing light.
We've learned already
that squeezed light
can suppress the noise.
If you squeeze light, something
which comes from the modes
where we apply squeezed
vacuum has been reduced.
I mean, it's what we
discussed already.
So the best we can do is
that the noise term is 0.
So what do we have now?
If we have a signal which is
finite and the noise is 0,
what is our precision
of measurement?
Well, it first looks like
the signal to noise ratio
is infinite.
But it's not quite that,
because if our signal is x,
it's a photon number.
And the signal x was sensitive
to the phase by cosine phi.
The sensitivity of our
measurement of the quantity
m with phase is
n times sine phi.
And this is smaller or equal
than n, where the equal sign is
obtained for 90 degrees.
So therefore, we have a
[? photon ?] number n.
We may absolutely know what the
initial [? photon ?] number is.
But now we want to measure
whether the phase is
different from pi over 2.
And the smallest change in our
signal which we can resolve
is that we get one photon less.
So that's the smallest
resolvable change
due to the [? photon ?]
nature of our detection.
And that implies that
the smallest phase
shift we can
resolve is 1 over n.
So this is more a
thought experiment,
now looking at the math and
seeing what is the best signal?
A dega A can never be larger
than [? photon ?] numbers,
so that's a resource.
We put in energy in
the terms of photons,
and then the best we can do is
that we don't have any noise.
And then we are simply
limited by the fact
that when we deviate from
the maximum output signal
because there is a phase
shift in the interferometer,
our sensitivity comes in grains,
is grainy by the [? photon ?]
number.
So I'm not telling you how
we achieve to get y equals 0.
The question is only
that at least the math
seems to make it possible.
So now we ask how to achieve
sub-shot noise precision.
So here we know this is at
least mathematically possible.
So we want to improve
this interferometer,
and the question is we
have to change something.
This interferometer, [INAUDIBLE]
we've seen [INAUDIBLE]
state is not giving
us any better result,
so we have three options now.
We can do something fancy in
the input state, use entangled
state.
We can use some very
fancy beam splitters,
or we can do something
special to the way
how we read out
the interferometer.
And all those three
are possibilities.
We can put in some
extra quantumness
into each of the three steps.
OK
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
WOLFGANG KETTERLE:
OK, the question
is can we do something
with the phase shift?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
WOLFGANG KETTERLE: I think
if we would do something
with the phase
shift, we would do--
you know, we would change
apples with oranges,
because we want to compare
different interferometers
by measuring the same thing.
And maybe as an
experimentalist say,
what I want to be
able to measure
I take a very, very thing glass
plate which just makes a very
small phase shift,
and I'm now comparing
different interferometers.
And when I put the glass
plate in and pull it out,
I want the person who reads
out the interferometer
to see a change.
So that's how I want to
compare the interferometers.
Actually, the question
you are raising
was in another way
also discussed today
at lunch with three of
my wonderful colleagues.
Namely what we discussed was
some recent papers, one of them
published in
Nature, which claims
precision better
than Heisenberg.
I mean, what I'm sort of
indicating to you is Heisenberg
should be the best
which can be achieved.
How can we do even
better than Heisenberg?
Well, and this was
actually related, Nancy,
to your question.
If you want to
measure magnetization
and you use some
nonlinear physics
where the photons, where
the magnetization involved
affects the photon field by
some higher power of what
you measure, you really
change what you measure.
Maybe I'm not
expressing it clearly.
If you measure magnetization
and you have a certain quantum
limit in measuring
the magnetization,
that's one thing.
But if you now bring
another material close
to your magnetization and this
material goes through a phase
shift, you sort of amplify
by a physical process
by a nonlinear Hamiltonian
what you want to measure.
And then of course
you can-- depending
on what kind of
nonlinear process
you're using-- you
can get a signal which
scales tremendously with
the number of photons you
put into your system.
So in other words, there
are loopholes like this,
and some of them led
to very fleshy papers.
And our lunch discussion
was that some of it
is really completely trivial.
And some papers
who claim that they
have seen a scaling
of the precision
with photon number which
is better than Heisenberg,
not 1 over n, maybe
1 over n square,
that some of those papers
were purely classical
and the only quantum
character of this paper
was the name of
Heisenberg in the title.
So it's not related to
any uncertainty relation,
but that's not what
we want to discuss.
Let me just spend
quickly-- let me see, yup.
We should the week with
something interesting and not
just shot noise.
So what I want to
use now is I want
to replace the beam
splitter by something
which involves Bell states.
So as the beam splitter
we do a massive creation
of bell states.
It's our entangler.
And our second beam
splitter is a Bell analyzer.
It is a disentangler.
So what I mean is the
following, we will actually
just put one photon
into this input beam,
and we will only
read out one channel.
So all these here are
only auxiliary modes.
This is how I make a special
quantum beam splitter.
And what we need
for this description
is essentially two gates.
We need a single qubit.
The single qubit
is the [INAUDIBLE]
which we have already discussed.
And in the dual-rail
representation
where its photon can be
in one of the two modes,
the [INAUDIBLE] is
simply connecting
the two modes in this way.
And we discussed
that the [INAUDIBLE]
can be described by a beam
splitter with a phase shift.
So in other words,
we need one element
which is a beam splitter
with a phase shift.
But this is only
acting on one qubits.
And now we want
to connect qubits
with a controlled NOT gate.
To remind you,
controlled NOT gate
is something where the
photons stay where they are.
But if the control bit is
1, it flips the target bit.
If the control bit is 0, nothing
happens to the target bit.
And we discussed
already that we can
realize one qubit with
one interferometer.
These are the dual-rails.
We always have one photon in two
states, this mode or that mode.
And know the other
qubit, one of the rails
can go through the
nonlinear Kerr medium.
If the bit is in c
through the phase
shift in the
nonlinear Kerr medium,
it flips the
[INAUDIBLE] down there,
and this the controlled knot.
So now we want to
use two qubits.
So I'm talking about,
in our fancy entangler
I'm just talking about
the first two rails here.
So we have those two rails.
The [INAUDIBLE] puts
us into a superposition
of the logical CO and 1.
And now after the
c-not gate, so we
are in a superposition
of-- just give me
a second-- we start here with 1.
Sorry, we start here with 1.
AUDIENCE: Excuse me.
WOLFGANG KETTERLE: Yeah?
I'm wrapping up.
This is my last.
AUDIENCE: One [INAUDIBLE]
minus 1 [INAUDIBLE].
WOLFGANG KETTERLE: The 0
[INAUDIBLE] in 0 plus 1.
And let me just finish that.
This is the target, year.
Sorry, it's correct.
We start with 0,
we start with 0.
So what we have here is
the product state of 0
plus 1 upstairs
and 0 downstairs.
But if we have a 1,
we flip the 0 to 1.
So therefore, what we have now
is the state 00 plus 1 1 over
square root 2.
And then we apply
our phase shifter.
And what we get out of this
state is 00 plus e to the 2i
phi times 1 1 over
square root 2.
So now by using sort of--
and now I should stop.
I know people are waiting.
But by using two of
those, I suddenly
have multiplied the phase
by 2, so something is now
sensitive to 2 phi.
And if I use n such, more
and more entanglement,
I will show you--
no class next week,
but in the following
week-- that we suddenly
have a term in our quantum
state which is e to the n phi.
And this gives us effect
of an in precision.
OK, have a good rest of
the week and we meet again
in a week and a half.